all right pricey yes pricey uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i'm from oakland
you're from oakland you live in oakland
currently
well i like i stay out here right now or
you stay in l.a but
yeah you're an oakland girl yeah and uh
tell me about your family you had both
your parents when you were young
um no not really no
where did you they were my grandparents
your grandparents
where was mom and dad uh they're in
prison
oh okay what were they in prison for
well they were when i was like a baby
so my grandma never really told me so
you don't even know
not really i mean my dad died now he got
out when i was 18.
okay so you were raised by my campaign
my mom's mom
and dad and how was your childhood it
was it was
cool kinda
yeah unless i got in trouble for
something yeah but a good childhood
yeah it was okay what kind of kid were
you in high school
uh i was distracted a lot
you were distracted yeah so i could like
skip classes sometimes
yeah did you finish high school no i was
no
i was like i was in juvenile hall until
two south of my 18th birthday
oh really yeah
so you uh you got into prostitution at
what age
18 right after i lost my virginity oh
wow
yeah you started working with a pimp or
yeah well somebody he just took me out
here
he just took he was crazy so
i didn't really have a choice to start
doing this
so do you feel like you were tricked
into it or
well i was really like he was really
crazy
he would hit us and stuff all the time
so
the way i grew up and the way he was
didn't go together i was just nervous
all the time
so i did everything he said because he
was
kind of violent and yeah he was super
violent
all right and how long were you with uh
with him
i got away from him after like six
months
how'd you get away we were
we were in like orange county one time
and then
i just when he dropped us off like 30
minutes later i just ran away and
stopped answering the calls
and then he disappeared yeah and then he
saw me
on vermont he started chasing me he got
out of the car and started chasing me
so it was crazy but you've been
without a pimp since then
or you've had other ones no i've had
another one but he was crazy too
so now i'm just doing it by myself
you're a renegade
yeah as they say do you prefer
working on your own yeah what are the
advantages and disadvantages of both
well the advantage is you don't have to
pay anybody right the disadvantage is
once people once a guy finds out another
pimp they're going to tell all the other
pips and
they can tap out bounce out that beat
you up take your money
so it's a rough it's a rough
lifestyle isn't it yeah have you had bad
things happen to you
yeah what kind of stuff has happened
i've been raped kidnapped
um held at gunpoint you know choked out
like struggled until i couldn't breathe
and then when i woke up you had to get
into my face so you know
this is not exactly the lifestyle you
probably dreamed of as a kid right
no i wanted to be art teacher you want
to be an art teacher
oldie i'm 25. you can still be our
teacher
you're you're a kid so maybe
i have to go back to school yeah it's
all doable
anything's possible especially at 25
right
do you have kids no i don't think i
could have kids anymore
why is that because all the stuff that
happened to me oh really
and does your is your
mom and dad out of prison now or not
just my dad
just your dad
and your grandparents they're
like up north do they know this is how
you're
supporting yourself when i got a car
accident a couple years ago they found
out because
the police have told them so
yeah they just found out a couple years
ago
and are drugs are part of your life i
i yeah i've done drugs before yeah
are you still using drugs
no i try to i try not to
okay it
just you know it's a very crazy way of
making a living right i mean
do you sometimes stand back and look at
this lifestyle you've made for yourself
and just
wonder why you're doing it yeah all the
time
all the time do you feel like you can't
get out
i know i can probably but it's like how
you just don't know how yeah
because this is what this is all you
know is that what you feel yeah
basically
i turned 18 lost my opportunity then got
taken out here yeah but i can assure you
that if you want to pursue an art being
an art teacher you could
you can make that happen very easily all
right
i'd probably try it [__]
what kind of emotions do you go through
in your life do you get depressed or
anxious or angry or anything like that
yeah sometimes you get sad that you do
it you know
right you have to deal with all these
people did you do you find it's
degrading or
yeah sometimes yeah because well you
have to dress sometimes in order
to get attention because everybody else
is outside naked
and tell me about the guys that pick you
up do you do you
do you like them do you tolerate them do
you
i have to do them in order to get paid
but do you
do you respect these guys i i've met
some guys that are
that are cool some guys are nice yeah
some guys are just crazy
or they try to give you fake money or
something yeah
are you saving money are you saving
money doing this
not really i mean i want to
but
it's hard right now it's like 100 girls
up and down everywhere
yeah there's a lot of girls walking the
streets yeah so it's hard to save money
a lot of competition out there yeah how
much were you making tonight
it really depends on like my location
right
so because i'm tall you know you're
you're six four yeah so i'm a dominatrix
yeah so you're a dominator yeah
for some for some of your clients
do you have dreams of doing something
like you know other than our teacher
like having kids and
a husband family stuff like that i want
to adopt some kids
because i feel like somebody needs a
parent
yeah absolutely i'm sure there's lots of
kids looking for a mom like you
exactly what's the hardest part of your
life
doing this yeah
i don't really do anything else
does it affect your love life
well i've never really had a love life
you've never been alone
no you're like i've been doing this
i'm sorry i've been doing this so and
before
18 i just went to school
do you feel like you were loved by your
grandparents
yeah kind of
do do you feel like you were loved at
some point by anyone yeah when i was
like a kid
yeah once i got like a teenager and up
and now
i don't know about the love too much
[Music]
you find this lifestyle is difficult
because so many people are up to
up to something shady up to some very
few
people are trustworthy and honest yeah
you never know whose car you're getting
in
and what they have planned right so
it makes it difficult how do you feel
like this has changed you this
doing this kind of work i just feel like
i look at the world different
i used to think everybody was nice all
the time and now
not so much yeah
does it change how you view man it
really changes how i view a lot of
people
you know men and women so
you think you're addicted to it or just
afraid to get out and do something else
i think it's worth afraid to because
then
i don't know if i'll have any money i
don't know if it's gonna make me like
get no worse predicament i don't know
and if somebody from my past sees me you
know
what have you learned about human nature
from doing this kind of work
that people really don't care about you
they look at you like a piece of meat
yeah that's got to affect your
self-worth self-esteem right
so when you're with the pimps what kind
of things
were going on um i remember at a wifey
when i first started
and then she she i guess she crashed
she just hit hit a pole you know so the
car wasn't messed up like that but he's
so crazy
he he knocked all her blood vessels
popped all of them in her eyes
to where she had to wear sunglasses for
two weeks at night time
and then he broke through her ribs and
tried to throw her out the window
because we lived on the second floor
so yeah so the stories we hear about
tim's are
sometimes true yeah he's really crazy
like
he'd hit me before right after i gave
his money he hit me because he was mad
at somebody he couldn't hit
so he was mad at somebody else but he
hit you
yeah because i was the closest one too
so and you give him all the money yeah
right after i handed him the money yeah
but but but every night you will give
your pimp all the money well yeah
because i was scared and you never you
never
get the money out of that relationship
well because you have to you have to run
away and escape
yeah so i feel like all the money you
make is their money
so like they're crazy like they'll
search you everything
i said they take your wigs off they make
you strip naked
they'll stick their fingers in your
[__] to make sure
you don't have any money you're not
hiding money yeah
what do you think why do you think so
many girls are working with pimps
even the ones that i interviewed that
say they they're not are very often are
i know i know that but you have to let
them let them hide there
not true a lot a lot of females are
scared into it
they don't have anywhere else to go they
feel like they're not good enough for
anybody else
or they get tricked into it so
and then they're afraid you're afraid to
get out you think yeah because a lot of
these guys be
fearing us so you don't feel free
to leave no because it's like we have
code like
if you don't have a pimp in your
renegade and then other pimps find out
they can do whatever they want to you
because who are you going to call so
that's what we got to think about too
yeah so
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's considering doing this kind
of work or something like it
i should just go to school and get a
regular job
life's gonna be so much easier
and you get risky requests from some of
your clients like without to do to do
things without a condom or things like
that
yeah people ask that all the time but
because there's a lot of girls out here
doing it
you know so i've been asked weird things
i've had people ask could i have sex
with their dog which is weird why would
you say yes to that
they want you to have sex with their
daughter yeah or guys wouldn't
have me watch didn't have sex with other
guys i've had some weird requests
yeah so
people are weird but to each his own i
guess
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
um
i don't know i just i try to find inner
peace that's basically it
gotta sometimes you gotta find inner
peace because you won't find it in the
world
besides art i like i just like animals
the kids
you like animals and kids yeah and i
like to eat food from different places
like place i've never been are things i
can't pronounce
have you traveled have you been around
the world well not around the world
but i've been like a couple other states
so on vacations or to work
well to work yeah so i stripped in texas
before like your pimp send you to
another city to make money
yeah yeah
all right pricey well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah
and i wish you the best of luck out
there thank you thank you very much
okay
you're so pretty thank you
you